and uh and who had a big game that night
norman powell was huge for them i
believe a career high
brown down the lane
right now it's a five rebound advantage
for the boston celtics over toronto good
screen
and the 16 footer by tatum right down
the chute for the celtics playing
downhill
when it gets an elite defender and just
goes right back by danny ainge
lob inside williams fronted him there
here comes brown nice defense in there
by terence davis yet it still goes
[ __ ] played 10 minutes in this one
they say he'll go 30 tonight
leaning forward foul called three
taken and hit can erase that 7-0 run
a three by brad wanamaker on the
previous possession
brown comes the other way from the
atlanta area when
cal played in the pac-12 tyson other one
good takes with two long rangers
i say unlikely because he hasn't even
played except like i said the two
minutes
down here shot clock at three tatum wow
what a beautiful rainbow
here's kemba walker with a one of five
first half in the books
working on sea academy gets free on a
screen from tice
got the shot away and in and a foul
silver
comes off the screen by tice and because
of that
round swerving into traffic here comes
tatum again walker in the corner this
time it goes down
come three of 11 and seven points
here's a floater by tatum that will drop
boston lost to milwaukee by seven they
beat portland by
four watts to miami by six that's a
three by tatum
outside and then they beat so he puts
that in
five minutes gone here in the third
walker outside
tatum on vanvleet walker three good
finger roll won't go tice is there to
clean the glass
he now has nine the other round what a
great transitional play for boston
nice job by boston of running those
raptors off that three-point line
round three bucket puts it in
difference of five seconds game clock
and shot clock are four and a half
seconds walker off balance good
that was a tough shot